le vrai fils et ponsard est mort depuis
le 2 décembre 2014
c'est ainsi que l'accusé ponsard débute
sa 18e édition dans l'après midi à la
barre de la cour d'assises de fort de
france et poursuit en déclarant j'ai
menti aux enquêteurs
j'ai menti à mes propres enfants ma vie
a basculé je ne suis pas un monstre
je n'ai pas voulu la mort de madame
française qui a révélé ce n'est que
lorsque le président de la cour
d'assises lui demande le mobile de son
acte qu'il avance au cours d'une visite
au domicile de pierre émile à balata
j'avais cru entendre madame france est
pierre émile déclaré à mon insu si ils
font ça c'est parce qu'elle commet
mobile surprenant c'est donc l'unique
raison qui aurait poussé pensa à aborder
l'enseignante au niveau du guichet
automatique à cluny
elle aurait ensuite selon lui accepté de
la rejoindre à son domicile à tiji par
la suite les choses se sont envenimées
une version des faits que la famille de
l'enseignante a du mal à accepter
vous l'avez déjà qu'il ne dirait rien et
je sais aussi que quand il dira la
vérité je saurai que c'est la vérité
ce qu'il a dit là c'est complètement
invraisemblable sur toute la longueur et
je ne peux pas y croire la matinée était
consacrée aux parties civiles
j'ai rapidement il fait le point sur
certaines rumeurs il déclare que s'il
acceptait de recevoir pour sa ex
compagnon de sa fille à son domicile
c'est tout simplement parce qu'il
craignait ces réactions très violentes
j'ai été victime moi de beaucoup de
rumeurs pour la plupart de ces rumeurs
elle venait de lui mais elle était
répétée par plusieurs personnes à qui
ils nous avaient dit et je tenais quand
même à remettre un peu les choses au
clair a apporté des précisions aux gens
qui avaient des doutes qui pouvaient
douter quoi grand moment d'émotion
clôturant la matinée le témoignage des
filles de la victime en larmes